[Musik]
china ist uns nicht so fern jedes kind
zwischen aachen und zarrentin ist mit
chinesischen spielzeug aufgewachsen und
jeder erwachsene hat ein smartphone oder
ein anderes elektronisches gerät das von
arbeiterinnen in china zusammengebaut
wurde auch in umgekehrter richtung
funktioniert der wirtschafts handels
deutsche mobil hersteller verkaufen bis
zu 40 prozent ihrer fahrzeuge nach china
doch wie mächtig ist das reich der mitte
mittlerweile
wie sehr müssen wir wertvorstellungen
akzeptieren die nicht unseren
entsprechen chinas umgang mit
minderheiten und die behandlung der
menschen in der früheren britischen
kronkolonie hongkong belasteten verziert
als prinz charles 1997 in hongkong war
um die britische kronkolonie an china
zurück zu geben da geht das versprechen
ein land zwei systeme hongkong sollte
bis 2047 ein unabhängiges justizsystem
behalten presse und meinungsfreiheit
genießen
mit einführung des drakonischen
sicherheits gesetzes ist das geschichte
die botschaft an die demonstranten in
hongkong ist unmissverständlich wer sich
antichinesische verhält kann im
gefängnis landen und zwar für sehr lang
370 festnahmen gab es gleich am ersten
tag die briten sehen das als klaren
vertragsbruch remake the speaker wir
haben angekündigt dass wir in diesem
fall für hongkonger mit britischem
sonderstatus einen neuen weg finden
werden um nach großbritannien kommen zu
können
evelyn erlauben hier zu leben und zu
arbeiten und dann die staatsbürgerschaft
zu beantragen
und genau das tun wir jetzt
peking schäumt vor wut und droht mit
gegenmaßnahmen
theoretisch könnten drei der 74
millionen hongkong als königreich
verloren gehen
ja ich denke darüber nach wenn ich dort
jetzt arbeiten kann ist das eine option
für mich ist das keine gute nachricht
wir haben jetzt ein jahr lang gekämpft
und sollten hier bleiben um weiter für
hongkong zu kämpfen
selbst wenn nur einige zehntausend
gingen würden die maßnahmen ihren zweck
wohl erfüllen
das ist schon etwas was china sehr
schmerzen würde wenn auf einmal viele
fachkräfte oder führungskräfte wirklich
mit den füßen abstimmen und aus hongkong
beziehen rexit briten wiederum könnte
expertise und das kapital aus hongkong
durchaus gebrauchen
vor allem aber macht london so klar dass
man dem treiben pekings nicht länger
untätig zusehen will nicht nur in
hongkong verstoßen die chinesen gegen
alle regeln auch mit den nachbarn im
südchinesischen meer und mit den uiguren
in xinjiang peking tut immer häufiger
was ist will bislang ungestraft wir
laufen auch einen offenen konflikt zu
mit mit china es wird schwieriger werden
auch eine wirtschaftsbeziehung und es
besser wenn wir selbst das heft in die
hand nehmen wenn die europäer und sich
selbst jetzt maßnahmen ergreifen um
diese chinesischen vorgehensweisen
einzudämmen um tatsächlich im diese
brüche von internationalem recht auch zu
sanktionieren und deutlich zu machen
dass china nicht so weiterfahren kann
sonst werden wir am ende von der wucht
dieses chinesischen vor dringend einfach
überrollt europa gilt der chinesischen
führung als papiertiger dabei gäbe es
maßnahmen die peking dazu bewegen
könnten sich an die regeln zu halten
eine ist chinesischen unternehmen den
zugang zu europäischen märkten zu
versperren
eine andere sich klar auf die seite
hongkongs zu stellen
die briten haben einen anfang gemacht
politisch ist das verhältnis zu china
seit 1989 immer komplizierter geworden
nach der niederschlagung der
demokratiebewegung auf dem
tiananmen-platz wurde mal in deutschland
schon misstrauisch seit hongkong mehr
und mehr probleme hat seinen status
heißt sonderzonen zu halten grübeln auch
deutsche politiker
ob man denn auch wirklich alles eingehen
sollte was möglich ist
das von china verabschiedete sogenannte
sicherheitsgesetz erlaubt den behörden
in hongkong ein hartes vorgehen gegen
alle aktivitäten die nach ihrer
auffassung die nationale sicherheit
chinas bedrohen
das gesetz bedeutet den bislang
schwersten eingriff in den
autonomiestatus von hongkong mit einem
neuen sicherheitsgesetz greift china in
hongkongs garantierte rechte ein wie nie
zuvor
doch deutschland tut sich schwer mit
einer reaktion erst eine woche nach
verabschiedung des gesetzes äußert sich
ganz vorsichtig der außenminister das
hohe maß an autonomie hongkongs darf
nicht ausgehöhlt werden
wir erwarten dass die freiheiten und die
rechte der bürgerinnen und bürger durch
das basic lohr und den grundsatz ein
land zwei systeme gewahrt werden heiko
maas hat oft das problem dass er sich zu
den aktuellen problemen nur mit großer
verspätung und äußert wegen der
verletzung internationaler verträge
hätte ich mir eine sehr klare sprache
der europäischen union und deutschlands
gewünscht hinter schweigsamen mauern
findet nun statt was vor corona stets
mit viel pomp ablief nur merkels
diplomatisches leise treten hat sich
nicht geändert so wichtig sind ihr
wirtschaft und handel selbst in der
union gibt es kritik an merkels ina kost
die wirtschaftliche zukunft europas
hängt auch von unserer glaubwürdigkeit
ab wenn wir unsere glaubwürdigkeit
allein aus kurzfristigen
wirtschaftlichen interesse aufs spiel
setzen werden wir auch unsere
wirtschaftlichen vorteile verlieren
denn auch die hoffnung dass chinas
kauflust aus der krise hilft könnte
trügen
europäische handelskammer schlug plastal
am denn zitat entscheidende teile der
chinesischen wirtschaft werden von
staatsbetrieben beherrscht wenn private
unternehmen unterdrückt oder ganz aus
dem markt gedrängt werden und das ist
wichtig für meine begriffe dass wir viel
stärker unsere deutschen interessen
wahrnehmen unsere wirtschaftsinteressen
auch in china durchsetzen die chinesen
setzen sie sehr radikal in deutschland
durch auch in der großen koalition geht
der konflikt ob deutschland dem neuen
machtvollen china auch mit einer neuen
politik begegnen müsse mein eindruck ist
dass die bundeskanzlerin noch in den
alten china zeiten gefangen ist es im
alten china wild verhaftet wo es vor
allem und wirtschaftsbeziehungen geht
sie unterschätzt die system
herausforderungen die
sicherheitspolitische auch die
gesellschaftspolitische herausforderung
und deshalb müssen wir als europäer da
gemeinsam stark und entschiedene
auftreten
genau das will natürlich durch ihre alte
china politik die strategische
partnerschaft findet immer weniger
unterstützung
china selbst machtvoll und fordernd
auftritt wie nie zuvor
ich begrüße professor hugo von der
bonner universität genauer vom center
for global studies der universität bonn
die wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen
zwischen deutschland beziehungsweise
europa und china
die sind sehr sehr eng wie abhängig ist
man voneinander
natürlich werde ich wieder vom nichts
von einseitigen abhängigkeit sprechen
sondern von sogenannter interdependenz
gegenseitige abhängigkeit wir kommen uns
noch bevorstehen wenn das erste pro tag
sind es zwischen deutschland und china
eine milliarde 1,5 milliarden güte
ausgetauscht und das ist sehr enden ich
meine deutschland ist natürlich sehr ab
einstige funktion als person automarkt
aber umgekehrt auch natürlich bei dieser
engen beziehung wo man ja schon fast von
freundschaft sprechen kann würden sie
sagen dass das deutsche prinzip dass
freundschaft auch kritik vertragen muss
auch für diese beziehung gilt
ich denke schon wir sehen schon dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland schon seit
jahren eine doppel strategie gegenüber
china erfahren
einer sei es in der kooperation nicht
abgrenzung nicht ausgrenzen
wenn es möglich neue gebiete zu
erschließen vor für die beide länder in
frage kommen um gegenseitige kooperation
zu vertiefen wohlstand ist wäre halt auf
andere seite natürlich hatte deutschland
nicht vergessen
scharfe worte kritiker gegenüber china
auszuüben insbesondere bin situation im
menschenrechtsbereich sich
verschlechtern ich glaub schon dass
diese doppelstrategie hat funktioniert
ja bei der hongkong frage werde ich ein
bisschen differenzieren es geht um
natürlich die durchsetzung des
nationalen
sicherheitsgesetze es kam dabei ist darf
an wie die pekinger regierung dieses
kriegs auslege wird wenn sie versuchen
massive uferlos das gesäß auszulegen in
dem sinne dass man missbraucht dann
würde ich behaupten dass das konzept der
freiheit 140 würde wahrscheinlich
scheitern aber wenn peking tatsächlich
daran bleibt nur sich zu kümmern
um die nationale sicherheit und dann
würde ich sagen dass das system hongkong
als eine fatalistische freies triton
wird weiterhin bleiben was das
eigentlich problem was peking versäumt
hatte ist die einführung der
direktwahlen ihr hongkong in berlin
begrüße ich mal reich holberg senior
fellow beim german marshall fund die usa
führen so kann man sagen einen
handelskrieg gegen china europa versucht
er ja einen ausgleich zu finden so
bisher nach dem motto wandel durch
handel
was würden sie sagen welcher umgang mit
china ist angemessen hat sowohl die usa
als auch europa haben aus meiner sicht
probleme im umgang mit china die usa
gehen um einiges härter vor heute
anderen teilweise auch gerungen
das ist von der form her ist es nicht
als ist man da sehr wenig sinnvoll aber
im prinzip von der substanz her ist es
nicht falsch während europa aus meiner
sicht mit dem festhalten an wandel durch
handel oder teilweise auch dem aufgeben
von dieser maxime aber dann vielleicht
neue variante davon noch mal hervorholen
da etwas verfolgt was aus meiner sicht
einfach nicht möglich es ist europa
möglicherweise in naiv im umgang mit
china oder ist es schlicht und einfach
das kalkül dass man bessere geschäfte
machen kann wenn man nicht so viel
kritisiert das ist natürlich mit kalkül
ich denke auch die maxime wandel durch
handel war von vornherein nie tragen da
muss ich fragen wie ich inwiefern bares
von anfang an
in den 90er jahren ernst gemeint und wie
viel davon war quasi vorgeschoben damit
man einen guten grund hatte weshalb man
auch mit einem regime das gerade seine
eigene brut herz demokratiebewegung
niedergemäht hatte auch weiterhin handel
betreiben kann also ich glaube dieser
aspekt dass profit maximieren es war
schon immer mit dabei und der es auf
jeden fall auch heute noch dass china
schon so viel macht dass andere sich
unterordnen müssen was macht eine firma
die im nordwesten chinas eine
produktionsstätte hat und feststellt
dass ihre arbeiterinnen und arbeiter
nicht so behandelt werden wie es
deutschen wertmaßstäben entspricht
im nordwesten chinas sollen mehr als
eine million juden und muslime
interniert seien in sogenannten und
erziehungs lagern sein kann eine firma
das ansprechen ohne ihre
produktionsbetriebe zu gefährden
wieder einmal ist doll coni sah zum
europaparlament gereist um mehr gehör zu
finden für sein volk die uiguren als
präsident des uigurischen weltkongresses
gilt er als die stimme des muslimischen
turkvolkes welches in der region
xinjiang im nordwesten chinas
systematisch unterdrückt misshandelt und
millionenfach in massen lagern
interniert wird wir bitten die
weltgemeinschaft druck auf china
auszuüben vor allem das europaparlament
sollte die gräueltaten gegen die uiguren
verurteilen damit dieser gene oder sieht
und die verbrechen in unserem volk
gestoppt werden
dutzende europäische darunter auch
namhafte deutsche unternehmen wie
beispielsweise volkswagen haben in der
region shenyang investiert in seinem
werk in der hauptstadt urumqi produziert
vw das modell santana vor allem für den
chinesischen markt volkswagen betont man
habe in dieser unterentwickelten region
aus rein wirtschaftlichen überlegungen
investiert experten gehen stattdessen
von politischem druck aus man muss
volkswagen fragen womit das unternehmen
leben möchte möchte es die präsenz
entschieden sagen beibehalten und die
regierung in peking befriedigen und gute
profite machen aber dann andererseits
muss es damit leben dass es werke in
einer region betreibt die ein
internierungslager system hat nicht nur
die lager sondern die gesamte region
xinjiang wird von peking digital
überwacht überall beobachten behörden
mit kameras und gesichtserkennung
millionen von menschen mit einer
speziellen app verschafft sich der
chinesische staat zugriff auf
mobiltelefone der bewohner sammelt
informationen wie die ethnische
zugehörigkeit einer person ihre
religiösen und politischen einstellungen
laut der menschenrechtsorganisation
human rights watch werden so bürger
verfolgt und eingesperrt
entwickelt wurde diese app vom
chinesischen militär konzern ctc mit dem
siemens zusammenarbeitet doch siemens
bestreitet an dieser app beteiligt zu
sein
ganz gleich ob firmen in china
produzieren oder indirekt den
chinesischen unterdrückungsapparat in
der region unterstützen
rein aus ethischen gründen müssten sie
jetzt konsequenzen ziehen heißt es wenn
eine deutsche firma merkt dass das alles
nicht so läuft wie es nach deutschen
maßstäben laufen müsste sollte diese
deutsche firma dann in irgendeiner weise
eingreifen daraus schlussfolgerungen und
ziehen sollte sie das sagen
ja natürlich muss man darum geht tieren
können wenn man so denkt wenn man die
realität liegende ganze werde unter dem
kopf da halte mich da müsste deutschland
nur miteinander kooperieren die deutsche
unternehmen nur durch dahin gehen wo man
erwartet die gleiche europäische
sicherheitsstandards vorherrschen
dann können sie sich mal vorstellen wie
viele länder in der welt die gleiche
menschen fest stand dass auch die hohe
moralische voraussetzungen und besitzen
wie die europäische union
das würde bedeuten prüft der europäische
wirtschaft aber ich rede von die
realität von der realität der globale
arbeitsaufteilung hätte deutschland
hätte europa so viel macht in
chinesische entwicklungen die sich nicht
mit unseren wertvorstellungen vertragen
durch kritischeren umgang zu korrigieren
es kommt aber darauf an wovon man
spricht also was nicht möglich ist zu
erreichen weder im bereich
menschenrechte an sich noch auch im
wirtschaftsbereich sind strukturelle
reformen also man versucht das system
fundamental zu ändern indem man druck
aus ähnliches ist natürlich auch war im
bereich menschenrechte das heißt es
unwahrscheinlich dass sich jetzt da
waren und nicht viel strukturell ändern
beziehungsweise langsam nichtsdestotrotz
ist es wichtig dinge anzusprechen sowohl
hinter verschlossenen türen also die
leise diplomatie als auch öffentlich die
laut diplomatique weil sich dadurch die
bedingungen für konkret betroffene
person konkret betroffen die
personengruppen
in der regel doch ändern weil letztlich
regierung eben nicht an den pranger
gestellt werden möchte und sobald sie
weiß dass die aufmerksamkeit auf einer
bestimmten gruppe oder auf einer
bestimmten person gerade bei personen
oder personengruppen ist wird mit diesen
personen in der regel auch besser und
gang halten sie um einen schritt
weiterzugehen demokratie in china
überhaupt für denkbar
die einwohner vom dürfe die haben schon
die möglichkeit dorfvorsteher zu werden
das sind millionen von millionen dürfe
die genießt schon seit 28 jahren diese
dorf demokratie angeblich und dann würde
übertragen auf kommunaler ebene in der
nähe von hongkong in condom provinz
wurde schon teilweise realisiert
langfristig betrachtet glaube ich es
geht um doch auch die frage wie man
partizipatorische dimension des systems
verstärken konnte ich rede nicht davon
eine möglichkeit der westliche
parlamentarische oder us-präsidenten
system zu kopieren nach china da gibt
keine große möglichkeit
aber wenn wir im sinne von
partizipatorische system dann können
dass demokratie nicht nur an wahren
demokratie ist und auch darum geht die
leute möglichst also geben zu
partizipieren an politische
entscheidungsprozess dann bin ich sehr
optimistisch warum sollen demokratie
richter nicht denkbar seien
also ich sage es so es ist natürlich
unter den derzeitigen umständen nicht
möglich weil eine partei an der macht
ist die seit jahrzehnten alles dafür tut
dass es nicht zu einem wandel in
richtung einer demokratischen form
kommen kann ja also die steht im weg die
tut alles dafür dass sich die
gesellschaft nicht außerhalb der
parteistrukturen organisieren kann
aber an sich also das argument das auch
von menschen millionen gebracht wird ist
chinesen sind einfach kulturell oder
sind nicht für demokratie geeignet das
ist das ist natürlich ziemlich gruber
unsere kulturell ist der kontakt zu
vieler wenig intensiv
chinesen lassen sich oder ließen sich
vor corona gerne vor neuschwanstein oder
in heidelberg fotografieren und deutsche
gerd auf der chinesischen mauer
in china wird man gerne europäische
popmusik aber wer hört hier schon peking
oper von einer mentalität einer
chinesischen mentalität zu sprechen ist
schwierig es gibt so viele verschiedene
volksgruppen verschiedene dialekte
verschiedene kulturen verschiedene
identitäten dass es eigentlich nicht
möglich ist von einer chinesischen
mentalität zu sprechen die regierung in
peking sieht das allerdings ganz anders
sie spricht von einem china
china ist gemäss seiner fläche das
viertgrößte land der welt mit 1,4
milliarden menschen gilt es als das
meist bevölkerte land der erde in dem
über 50 nationalitäten anerkannt sind
wie leben menschen in einem so
vielfältigen staat miteinander gibt es
verbindende traditionen und
wertvorstellungen vielleicht auch den
gedanken einer historischen identität
das historische bewusstsein ist schon
stark aber es ist nicht ein wenig weil
china so viele facetten hat und insofern
ist es eine verflochtene identität die
in china immer wieder neu gebündelt oder
werden muss oder auch manchmal
auseinander fällt
china hat in seiner geschichte immer
wieder erlebt wie dynastien zugrunde
gingen und nach dem zerfall gewaltsam
vereinigt wurden welche bedeutung hat
diese vergangenheit für die bevölkerung
das ist sehr stark im bewusstsein
verankert dass nichts auf ewig
zusammenbleibt sondern alles irgendwann
wieder auseinander fällt und dann wieder
neu zusammen gebracht werden muss
konnten denn religiöse vorstellungen
dabei halt geben also der religions-
begriff selber den gibt es so in china
nicht aber natürlich gibt es brauchtümer
und es gibt auch glaubensvorstellungen
und da gibt es auch immer wieder und bis
in die gegenwart konflikte zwischen dem
staat und der staatlichen administration
und religionsgemeinschaften
chinesische kinder lernen von geburt an
die familie als wichtigste größe und
schutzraum zu sehen
ihr leben lang bleiben sie das kind
ihrer eltern und respektieren diese
hierarchie
dieser gedanke ist auch in der
konfuzianischen philosophie begründet
die grundidee ist dass der mensch
erziehbar ist dass der mensch sich
selber erziehen sollte und dass er dazu
natürlich auch angeleitet werden soll um
ein moralisch sozial ja auch für sich
persönlich guter mensch zu sein der
gedanke der erziehbar kite setzt sich in
den beziehungen der menschen
untereinander fort die frage ist ob er
auch den staat legitimierte seine
bevölkerung durch überwachung zu
erziehen
ich bin ganz sicher dass es in china wo
es ja sehr viel protestpotenzial immer
gegeben hat und auch immer noch gibt
dass sich die menschen irgendwann auch
lehrern gegen systeme die sie all zu
sehr einengen china verändert sich die
westlichen einflüsse sind nicht zu
übersehen
davon profitieren einige im land doch zu
welchem preis für andere wie lange kann
steigender wohlstand für die fehlenden
mitspracherechte entschädigen und werden
die chinesen irgendwann verstehen warum
wir im westen die freiheit des einzelnen
für das höchste gut halten
die kommunistische partei chinas
verspricht dem volk wohlstand und
sicherheit
doch es ist keine regierung des volkes
sondern eine regierung für das volk
wohlwollend könnte man es mit der idee
des philosophen staates nach plateau
vergleichen
aber es ist ein autoritäres system
die partei ist der souverän wo liegt die
grenze zum totalitären staat und wird zu
überschritten
wie sehen die konfuzius institute dass
die es ja auch in deutschland gibt wie
gehen sie damit um
im namen von konfuzius weltweit werben
rund 500 institute mit dem namen des
chinesischen philosophen für ihr
programm chinesische kultur soll hier
vermittelt werden und die chinesische
sprache
in deutschland gibt es inzwischen 19
konfuzius institute das in nürnberg
gehört zu einem der ersten hierzulande
jan schulak leitet die einrichtung seit
14 jahren
sie sieht sich und ihr team als
kulturelle vermittler sie wissen
sicherlich auch dass china der
wichtigste und der größte handelspartner
deutschlands ist und wird es gelingen
der zusammenarbeit sie natürlich
sprachkenntnisse kenntnisse über kultur
über sitten und gebräuche sehr wichtig
die konfuzius institute geben sich als
harmlose bildungseinrichtungen aus doch
sie unterstehen der chinesischen kultur
behörde handball die wiederum der
zentralen propagandaabteilung der
kommunistischen partei chinas
unterstellt ist für ihre erfolgreiche
einflussnahme weltweit wurde die hand an
direktorin von den parteikadern
ausgezeichnet konfuzius institute sind
ein wichtiger bestandteil unserer soft
power wir wollen chinas einfluss
erweitern
all das hängt von unseren lehrern den
konfuzius instituten und der sprache
soft power bedeutet im falle chinas die
subtile einflussnahme und die
vermittlung der eigenen werte china soll
nicht als bedrohliche expansive
wirtschafts und militärmacht
wahrgenommen werde
kritische menschenrechtsverletzungen
werden unter den tisch gekehrt in den
konfuzius instituten werden sie keine
debatten darüber was in china passiert
nämlich die verfolgung von tibetern von
goren von menschenrechtsanwälten finden
bei den konfuzius instituten handelt es
sich um institute die letztendlich das
image der kommunistische partei
aufhübschen sollen bayern unterstützt
als einziges bundesland seine drei
konfuzius institute mit direkten
zuschüssen der staatsregierung knapp
350.000 euro waren es allein für das
institut in nürnberg in den letzten
sechs jahren der spd abgeordnete im
bayerischen landtag markus rinderspacher
sieht es kritisch dass bayern
ausgerechnet chinesische institute
finanziert die im verdacht stehen in
florenz im und spionage zu betreiben
ich nehme die meldungen des
bundesverfassungsschutzes sehr ernst die
sagen nämlich dass man sehr vorsichtig
sein muss dass china seine
einflusssphäre immer weiter ausbaut und
dass die konfuzius institute hier eine
aktive rolle spielen
das heißt studierende werden aus
gespitzelt es wird in öffentliche
debatten eingegriffen
auch auf manipulative art und weise und
von akademischer freiheit kann bei den
konfuzius instituten überhaupt keine
rede sein
die bayerischen regierungsfraktionen
haben im landtag entschieden die
konfuzius institute weiter zu
finanzieren
die propaganda sei nicht erkennbar so
wichtig scheint der wirtschaftspartner
china zu sein
die kritik zur einschüchterung und
einmischung scheint in bayern verhallt
ob das im sinne des großen chinesischen
philosophen konfuzius wäre ist fraglich
konfuzius wollte ja dass der mensch
ständig an sich arbeitet dass er sich
weiterentwickelt dass er sich anstrengen
soll ist das immer noch ein antrieb im
heutigen china ja sicherlich ich meine
der hintergrund ist ja dass wir halt
keine religion haben nicht in china
china also für die und christentum
buddhismus sind eingeführt da von außen
und der konfuzius erwartete von der
menschen
eigene anstrengungen wenn man nach vorne
kommen mich nach oben kommen möchte man
musste sich kultivieren muss bambus
fleißig arbeiten weil man davon ausgeht
dass es niemand die helfen könnte
innsbruck kann gott der überirdisch
übervater der existierte nicht dem du
musst auf der erde hart arbeiten um nach
vorne zu kommen
in sofia dieses motiv diese motivation
es nach wie vor ein anträge für alle
menschen die gerne sich bereichen aber
auch karriere machen möchte
das wäre es gewesen der transrapid
sollte in zehn minuten vom münchner
hauptbahnhof zum flughafen fahren war
sogar einmal in strecke geplant von
hamburg nach berlin
aber es blieb bei den tests im emsland
der transrapid in den 60er und 70er
jahren in deutschland entwickelt und
dann irgendwann nach china verkauft in
shanghai werden und tatsächlich von der
innenstadt zum flughafen aber eben nicht
mehr in deutschland so ist es mit viel
hochtechnologie passiert viele jahre
lang mittlerweile allerdings produziert
china selbst hochtechnologie
entwickelt hochtechnologie ist
seinerzeit selbst voraus und wird damit
zum großen konkurrenten auch für
deutschland die zeiten als china noch
die billige werkbank des westens war
sind vorbei
mit dem plan made in china 2025 strebt
das land die weltweite marktführerschaft
in allen wichtigen industriezweigen der
zukunft an
wie schnell der chinesische marken
westliche produkte zurückdrängen können
hat deutschlands am beispiel der
solarindustrie schon erfahren müssen
man hat einfach auch geglaubt na ja wir
haben diese deutsche kompetenz so dieses
hoch halten der deutsche ingenieur kann
eben probleme lösen der chinese kann
andererseits nur dinge kopieren und
nachmachen
das ist uns an dieser stelle sehr auf
die füße gefallen wir haben diese
technologie aufgepäppelt mit
entsprechenden milliarden summen bei
unserer energiewende und haben uns zu
dem zeitpunkt als diese als diese
entscheidung anstand überhaupt nicht
vorstellen können was die chinesen in
der lage wären hier technologieführer zu
werden
selbst alteingesessene branchen sind
bedroht denn china bringt innovationen
viel schneller zur marktreife als europa
oder sogar amerika die deutsche
automobilindustrie muss in china mit
rund 500 staatlich geförderten e-auto
firmen konkurrieren im logistikbereich
propagiert china die neue seidenstraße
und bietet komplettpakete für den ausbau
der infrastruktur samt förderbank kredit
an großen vorsprung hat china schon
heute bei den digitalen technologien für
die digitale seidenstraße meldet china
jedes jahr 30.000 patente an zweieinhalb
mal so viele wie die usa
der vorteil der chinesin mit firmen wie
huawei alibaba oder tencent verfügen sie
über eine gewaltige manpower und
unbegrenzte datenmengen in china kommt
natürlich noch im schuh wie so vieles
das gesetz der großen zahl wenn sie sich
anschauen das bei vw allein 80.000
beschäftigte sich nur um forschung und
entwicklung kümmern so viele ingenieure
finden sie bei uns
überhaupt nicht die dass die das machen
könnten also hier muss ich sagen das ist
kein grund den kopf in den sand zu
stecken
aber hier ein bereich kmu sehr große
hoffnung sich zu machen über eine
fundamentalen sprung europas oder der
deutschen in die zukunft um die chinesen
noch mal hin zu holen oder gar zum
überholen halt die im grunde genommen
für illusorisch
eine große gefahr steckt in dem rasend
schnellen wachstum der chinesischen
digitaltechnik schon soll das social
scoring system landesweit eingeführt
werden
ein weiterer schritt zur totalen
überwachung der chinesischen bevölkerung
mit gravierenden folgen auch für den
westen
was passiert wenn die chinesen mit so
einer aussage wie wir sind mit unserer
technik in der lage eine millionenstadt
wie lagos unter kontrolle zu bringen
dass da keine kriminalität mehr herrscht
dass die öffentliche ordnung
sichergestellt wird und die chinesen in
der lage sind das im mexiko city zu tun
in lagos zu tun
in jakarta zu tun und wir haben darauf
keine antwort das einzige was wir sagen
können ist ja das ist aber eine
unzulässige überwachung wenn die
chinesen mit dieser technologie in der
lage sind in entwicklungs und
schwellenländern konkrete probleme vor
ort zu lösen dann haben wir ein echtes
problem weil wir darauf keine antwort
haben weil dann hilflos sind dennoch
europa wacht wenn auch langsam auf in
bereichen wie dem klimawandel akzeptiert
die eu china als partner
gleichzeitig bleibt china ein konkurrent
für europa nicht nur in der wirtschaft
sondern und das ist neu
vor allem mit blick auf das system china
fordert westliche werte offen heraus es
stellt seinen staatskapitalismus gegen
die idee der freien marktwirtschaft und
hat ein eigenes erfolgreiches internet
mit zensur und staatlicher kontrolle
etabliert als deutscher allein als
franzosen allein wird man an der stelle
nichts bewirken können das wird nur
gehen wenn man als eu zb im handel oder
im bereich von investitionen dann auch
den chinesen klar sagt das sind unsere
positionen dass es nicht verhandelbar
und an der stelle müsst ihr uns auch
entgegenkommen staaten wie ungarn oder
griechenland überlassen bereits teile
ihrer infrastruktur den chinesen wichtig
wäre stattdessen eine gemeinsame
europäische industriepolitik die
wettbewerbsfähig ist und
wettbewerbsfähig heißt erfolgreich
technologien anzubieten die zugleich
freiheit und menschenwürde des
individuums achten denken europäer und
amerikaner möglicherweise systembedingt
in zu kurzen zeitabschnitten kann man in
china in längeren entwicklungs
abschnitten denken
die schienen sind denke in der tat viel
langfristiger als die europäische und
die amerikanische kollegin kollege von
den profis hier zum beispiel china das
ist nur 40 jahre hier nach dem european
reform eingeleitet hat aber diese 40
jahre hat enorme umbrüche hier
vorgebrachte so dass man jetzt im westen
angst hat dass china alles verändern
könnte was man im westen erreicht hat
unter der vorstellung dass diese partie
um die in china sich abspielt ein ende
des staatsdieners sein könnte also man
hat keine gebote mehr man hat angst er
hat probleme mit der perspektive dass
china ist wird dringen könnte
ich betrachte china ist alles was ich
natürlich passt elias provisorisch in
sofia ist es ein bisschen übertrieben
wenn man die sachen kurzfristig
betrachtet würden sie sagen dass china
so etwas wie die weltherrschaft erobern
will weltherrschaft ist ein großes wort
also worum es der kommunistischen partei
vor allen dingen geht in china ist ihre
eigene macht abzusichern
das tut sie auch diversen wegen das eine
ist weiterer wirtschaftlicher wachstum
das wird schwieriger das heißt braucht
andere legitimation quellen es heißt das
eine ist dass sie tatsächlich im ausland
anerkennung recht für ihre
regierungsform und auch ihre eigenen
standards immer stärker durchsetzen kann
also billig war ihr eigenes modell sie
bilden nicht dass jedes land auf der
welt so wird china aber sie möchte dass
jede gruppe jeder mensch geht s lang
wandnischen tabus und die chinesischen
interessen respektiert und sich
automatisch in übereinstimmung mit
diesen interessen verhält auf diesen
gleisen im duisburger hafen kommen
mittlerweile pro woche mehr als 50 züge
aus china an züge zum beispiel aus
chongqing die beladen sind mit waren aus
china für deutschland und für europa das
aufstieg zur wirtschaftsmacht
möglicherweise zur weltmacht scheint
unaufhaltsam lange erwartete man dass
sich das land mit zunehmendem wohlstand
demokratisieren würde doch das gegenteil
ist der fall
die kommunistische partei chinas willst
mit allen mitteln an der macht halten
und dafür werden gesellschaft und
wirtschaft im eigenen land auf linie
gebracht und es wird ein weitreichendes
programm entwickelt mit dem china die
westlichen demokratien beeinflussen
möchte
dabei setzt es nicht nur seine
wirtschaftsmacht ein sondern das
versucht die gesamte bandbreite seiner
politik dafür einzusetzen
güterzüge die mit chinesischen waren
nach duisburg rollen auch sie gehören
zum projekt neue seidenstraße mit den
pekings führung neue handelsrouten und
märkte erschließen will neue schienen
straßen und entlang der seewege häfen
von china durch asien und afrika bis
nach europa ein riesiges
infrastrukturprojekt für das vorhaben
hat china allein in den vergangenen fünf
jahren und 90 milliarden us dollar
investiert eine studie der
eu-handelskammer in china kritisiert
jetzt eu unternehmen würden bei
aufträgen für die seitenstraßen
initiative englisch welt in roth
initiativ benachteiligt was ist für
europäische industrie dabei zu holen und
das ergebnis war etwas niederschmetternd
gerade mal 20 firmen waren dieses
projekt eingebunden über 90 prozent der
ganze produkte und services in diesem
welteroth projekten kommt von
chinesischer seite für uns springt der
relativ wenig daraus dass chinas führung
bei projekten der neuen seidenstraße
chinesische unternehmen bevorzugt
kritisieren beobachter seit langem auf
der wirtschaftlichen seite geht's waging
darum weiter märkte für chinas
unternehmen zu öffnen und zu sichern und
auch die auftragsbücher chinesische
unternehmen zu füllen generell geht es
der chinesischen führung mit der neuen
seidenstraße darum ihre legitimität zu
stärken
die kommunistische regierung stärkt
chinas wirtschaft und damit auch ihren
eigenen führungsanspruch so eder
die interessen von eu-unternehmen
spielten in peking allenfalls eine
nachgeordnete rolle
wir sind das mitten in duisburg und ich
begrüße den vorstandsvorsitzenden des
duisburger hafens erich staake aus ihrem
erleben aus ihrem umgang was würden sie
sagen was sind die stärken der chinesen
und was sind die schwächen
die chinesen haben einen klaren plan das
ist nicht nur im politischen umfeld so
sondern das kann man also auch mit dem
unternehmen aber den unternehmen
beobachten der mit klarer zielsetzung
gehen sie wollen also gut konzipierte
strategie und das eigentlich förderlich
weil man war es ziemlich genau wohin sie
wollen was in unserer branche ich kann
nur für meine branche meine erfahrung
sprechen schwächen
sicherlich ist es so dass in der
logistik china das ist bekannt nicht
unbedingt eine spitzenposition weltweit
einem deutschland ist seit vielen jahren
logistik weltmeister wir sind da sehr
sehr stark nicht nur weil wir die königs
und der elz und schenkers haben sondern
weil wir große mittelständler haben die
europäische weise weltweit sind netze
auch unterhalten und da sehr aktiv und
sehr erfolgreich sind und da haben die
chinesen sich habe ich noch aufzuholen
nun heißt diese verbindung ja gar nicht
mehr so aber ursprünglich sprach man
immer von der neuen seidenstraße
das klingt ein bisschen poetisch das
erinnert an die geschichte
würden sie sagen das ist auch eine
verwirklichung eines chinesischen traums
oder ist es schlicht und einfach kühl
kalkulierte wirtschafts und machtpolitik
und entspricht dem wunsch chinas
möglichst nah und möglichst intensiv mit
zu mischen hier wahrscheinlich ist es
eine mischung aus beiden
die chinesen haben natürlich sehr viel
getan in den letzten 2 insbesondere
letzten zwei jahrzehnten um anschluss zu
finden natürlich spielen sicherlich
geostrategische überlegungen eine rolle
denn sie sich nur an was da in den
chinesischen meer sich abspielt da gibt
es viele konflikte oder potenzielle
konflikte und dass die chinesen von
ihrem anspruch als zweitgrößte
wirtschaftsnation der welt natürlich
gerade auch was die handelswege angeht
möglichst unabhängig agieren wollen ist
nachvollziehbar insofern ist das
sicherlich auch klare geostrategische
initiative gewesen über den landweg
europa zu erreichen und vielleicht auch
begleiten damit natürlich auch die
verbindungen zu den entlang der
seidenstraße angesiedelten
staaten zu optimieren wenn wir ehrlich
sind wer von uns in europa hat den über
kaukasus länder gesprochen oder über die
länder der früheren sowjetunion die
jetzt in china an grenzen die haben wir
teilweise gar nicht gekannt so die alle
die meisten von denen haben die chance
genutzt und für ihre wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und das ist ja per se erst
mal nicht negativ denn uns stehen noch
die gleichen möglichkeiten offen gibt es
etwas was sie sich wünschen würden im
umgang mit china als wirtschaftsmacht
lesen am main tragen ganz eindeutig und
dazu gehört natürlich die beiden rot in
meschede einfach an einen
handelsnetzwerk zu bauen das sicherlich
über die reinen handelsrouten hinaus
geht sondern natürlich auch
einflusssphären schafft das wissen wir
alle da macht auch keinen hehl draus
die europäer haben wir überhaupt kein
konzept und ich habe das seit vielen
vielen jahren immer wieder angemahnt und
dann gesagt dass es wird zeit dass
europa in sich eine konzeption
entwickelt wie man mit so einer
initiative die unumkehrbar ist umgehen
will
am anfang war die war die wahl gab es
sogar eine gewisse euphorie kann mich
noch gut erinnern und in den letzten
jahren ist das dann ein wenig gekippt
aus welchen gründen auch immer man hat
das jetzt als gefahr betrachtet und so
weiter für uns ist immer wichtig dass
wir jede verbindung die wir eingehen
immer auf augenhöhe mit unseren
chinesischen partnern auch eingehen und
die erfahrungen sind durchweg positiv
tritt europa wirtschaftlich und
politisch energisch genug auf oder ist
man zu träge und tsunami vom umgang
china es wurde erwähnt ist flächenmäßig
das viertgrößte land der welt hat 14
milliarden menschen 500 millionärin aber
eben auch mehr als 40 millionen arme und
europäische union hat immerhin rund 450
millionen einwohner ganz europa hätte
700 und ist der größte gemeinsame
wirtschaftsraum der erde
insofern könnte europa als ganzes wenn
es zusammenhält durchaus auf augenhöhe
mit china verhandlung
der anspruch ist riesig als ursula von
der leyen eu-kommissionspräsident in
wird fordert sie forsch eine neue rolle
für europa in der welt eine
geopolitische kommission wolle sie
führen eine die mit den supermächten auf
augenhöhe verhandelt europa muss auch
die sprache der macht lernen so hat es
der designierte hohe beauftragte
formuliert probleme gibt es mit china
europa sucht noch nach einer strategie
wie es der super handelns macht
selbstbewusst gegenüber treten kann
einem land das europäische werte mit
füßen tritt und europa während der
pandemie mit falschinformationen über
zielt ich habe das schon ein paar mal
gesagt dass europa sich bislang china
gegenüber zu naiv falken hat wir
brauchen einen realistischen ansatz um
unsere werte zu verteidigen
nur too die fans während der korona
krise nutzen russland und china die
anfängliche schwäche der eu gnadenlos
aus mit großem propaganda aufwand
liefern sie masken und medizinischer
ausrüstung nach italien und verstärken
damit das bild eines unsolidarischen
europas
europa will mitreden auf der welt so
viel ist klar
den beweis aber dass die eu die sprache
der mächtigen beherrscht den muss die
neue chefin noch erbringen
ich habe mir in beiden welten gelebt was
würden sie sagen wie soll deutschland
wie soll europa mit der neuen weltmacht
china umgehen ich glaube probleme die
uns konfrontieren die es sind dinge die
ein einziges land oder einem kontinent
überhaupt nicht an ein beseitigen könnte
klimawandel verbreitung von nuklearen
waffen system internationaler
terrorismus reiche und arme unterschied
und und das sind probleme die man ein
durch abgrenzung nicht erreichen
seitigen könnte muss man deswegen glaube
ich bei allem respekt vor unterschied
kritik menschenrechtsfrage muss man doch
auch versuchen mädchen hatte gerade
mechanismus zu bewahren tore auszubauen
um diese probleme die unsicherheit die
prämien für alle einander sind zu
reduzieren
deutschland braucht erstens eine
realistische einschätzung dass die
kommune china ist es ist wahnsinnig
schwer in china etwas zu verändern
strukturell durch handel und vor allen
dingen muss deutschland wegkommen von
der angst china hätte wahnsinnig viel
macht wirtschaft mit über uns ja es gibt
einige branchen wie die
automobilindustrie ihre noch einige
andere große unternehmen sind stark vom
chinesischen markt abhängig
das ist aber nur ein teil ein kleiner
teil lässt sich der deutschen wirtschaft
ein wichtiger teil aber es ist nicht die
gesamte deutsche wirtschaft die ich viel
weniger ablehnt als wir häufig sagen und
auch bei den teilen die abhängig sind
es ist tatsächlich so dass viel wert in
china selbst kreiert wird das als dann
hat man kann letztlich um einiges sich
einiges mehr leisten als man häufig
denkt an buschbeck wahrscheinlich wird
deutschland keinen wandel in china
erreichen die europäische union könnte
aber einige
ihrer werte auch in china geschäft
vertreten wenn sie geschlossen auftritt
europa als wertegemeinschaft und
wirtschaftsmacht könnte selbstbewusst
mit allen anderen großen spielern
handeln
auch mit china aber auch europa müsste
sich dafür weiter entwickeln
in der vielfalt europas gibt es genügend
unternehmer die das erkannt haben und
nicht in freund feind denken verharren
sondern neue wege der zusammenarbeit
suchen
[Musik]